hey everyone its Johanna here so you
have done your workout you have worked
really hard you're sweaty and now it's
time to cool down and do your stretches
I'm going to show you a really quick
five minutes
total body stretches to lengthen and
relax your muscles so let's start let's
start by placing your lap food on the
floor keeping your left leg and your
right legs 90 degrees what we want to do
is to stretch our right hip flexor out
so all we want to do is to shift our
body weight forward and what you should
be feeling is your right hip flexor
things stretched out and what we want is
to hold each stretch for 15 seconds long
release and hold it for another 15
seconds so keep your body upright
release slightly and now let's hold for
another 15 seconds if you don't feel it
try to shoot your body weight
forward okay so you should really be
feeling you're right
you being stretched out good job now
just ship your body weight back and what
we want to be stretching is the
hamstrings on our left leg so just
stretch out and just gently reach
forward there you go and just whole
weight remember everybody's flexibility
level is different so take it on your
own piece and you should feel mouth
discomfort really slightly and now just
stretch it again and just reach forward
and stretch the more you breathe out the
further you will be able to reach and do
not all your prep it's all about
relaxing kill each other and now bring
it back up what what do is to twist our
torso to do the stretch on our waist so
right palm facing outwards left hand all
the way and just look as far back as you
can with your head and just feel your
waist and your torso being stretched out
good brother you look deeper you will be
very good holy release gently and now
let's stretch it out again okay keeping
your chest and your back upright all the
time so no hunching are really keeping
your back straight
good job and now let's bring our left
leg back and all we want to do is to
pull it and stretch our quads okay same
thing the further and the deeper you
pull and touch of you it is apart the
more you're feeling so just remember to
take it in and the own pace do not force
your muscles to stretch too far
because you will only injure yourself so
release again and now let's stretch it
out again good job
support your hands by placing it on the
floor
very good and now just release it what
we're going to do now is exactly the
same on the other side so right leg up
left leg down and now shape your body
weight forward and feel your hip flexor
being stretched out same thing open 15
seconds release and then stretch for
another 15 seconds if you don't feel it
you can always inch forward and feel
this stretch quite a bit if flex left
right remember to always keep your body
upright all the time release and stretch
it out again get breathe out and breathe
in slow your breathing down to is what
you want is to clean down good job
and now just and your knees and just
stretch your white hamstrings okay you
should feel the stretch right at your
hamstrings just reach forward as far as
you can
very good releases slightly and now
let's go back down and hope for another
15 seconds if you were to stretch every
day you will improve your flexibility so
try to spend five to ten minutes every
day to do quick stretches to improve
your flexibility and now let's come back
up and the twist your torso so left
palms facing outwards right hand on your
waist and just move as far back as you
can okay keeping your back and your
chest upright doing well by keeping your
back upright you should feel the flag
being stretched down as well release and
once more
twist and look
good job and now let's just bring our
right leg back and to stretch on our
plots so just pull it in and feel the
stretch on your class
okay
listen
and let's stretch once more all these
static structures should only be done
after your workout and not before your
workout so remember to warm up is not to
do any stretches static stretches at all
good job
releasing and now let's just get let's
stretch our arm out so place your arms
together your hands together keep your
back straight and squeeze your shoulders
together and just feel the stretch on
your arms and your shoulder blades and
the higher you lift it the deeper and
you will feel the scratch okay remember
to open up your chest at the same time
so don't hunch you forward too much or
really open it up lift your arms higher
up and feel the stretch between your
shoulder blades and your hands you can
feel slightly forward for a deeper
stretch
release it and let's do it once more
[Music]
all right CEO discretion in arms
especially if you have just done your
arms break out and go to your shoulder
blades and now just release and the
final stretch downwards don't it's a
really good tool to body stretch and
it's really good to stretch your cuffs
on its own so that's just good all poles
and floor come up you want your bum to
be facing towards the ceiling and just
keep your body straight and just stretch
out keep your back straight and just
stretch out okay the goal is to have
your heels on the floor if you can't do
that you can just slowly step forward
and stretch your calves out you're going
you jump then just hold stretch your
back push your bum up and feel your
calves being stretched out at the same
time all right
really slightly and let's go into the
position
stretch it out pop it in slowly and easy
and now let's just go down into a child
pose and just realize
[Music]
that was a quick five minutes total body
stretches which you should do after
every workout if you want a deeper
stretch repeated antalya moves again if
you want to improve on your flexibility
you should stretch every day do not skip
on your stretches they are as important
as your workout routine for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do you follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
to stay connected with me thanks guys
you